imagine that you've provisioned and  configure a virtual machine for your Dev  environment and then you decide to  create an identical virtual machine for  your test environment are you confident  that you can recreate the same  configuration  watch this short to know more about how  terraform handles such scenarios  you might be thinking of manually  copying the code but this is a  cumbersome process where every little  change has to be applied error-free  across all environments instead you can  use terraform modules  with terraform you can place your code  inside a module and reuse that module in  multiple places  that way any changes you make to the  module are reflected across all  environments that you plan to reuse  if you need to update the code you will  need to do so in one location  are you ready to learn more click on the  three dots and then click on the link in  the description box to enroll in the  getting started with terraform for  Google Cloud course see you there